that's why Fonz I want to get into this
which was a weird thing you know I mean
I don't understand where in your life
this characteristic I mean you came up
with this personality thing so I texted
Gilbert's last maybe on Thursday yeah
Oh Wednesday I said hey did you still
want to meet with the commercial agent
that I just want to say this is that I
don't see the full name agency yeah like
I say that okay but when I came to LA
there was a Korean dude who you know
assigned me to a commercial agent he was
an agent his name was what can I say it
because you're gonna make look Gilbert
look bad maybe he's gonna listen to this
okay just don't say his name just say
his first name Lawrence oh yeah my
little friend Lawrence and then he
created his own commercial agency and
they're pretty big they have a
theatrical Department now he's the head
of it and he's helped a lot of comedians
out and stuff like that so I called
Lawrence last week and go can you sign
or maybe consider signing my friend
Gilbert hmm and because my podcast he's
very talented this and that and then I
had kalila Cole Gilbert to say that this
I set up this meeting I texted them and
what did Gilbert's a nice I said hey did
you still want to meet with Lawrence and
his response in one text with a period
at the end was I'm taking meetings I'm
taking meetings and I thought what did I
text you back that's the grossest thing
you've ever seen man continue guys
meetings I'm gonna defend myself
that's so ungrateful it's like if
somebody did that for me I would say yes
thank you so much not I'm taking
meetings because I'll tell you why that
that [ __ ] thing is so gross is you're
not taking me there are no other
meetings that you have you know let me
say so it wasn't jokey because I'll tell
you why if it was jokey you don't mean
because if I somebody had done that to
me and I would I would have said I'm
taking meetings tax lol now yeah yeah
yeah what how you work
however I'm taking meetings period no
joke
so then that's the only way you can like
you know interpret that is that he is
really serious in fact if you hadn't put
a period in the back of it it would have
been much better because then that's
jokey but you put a period like that's
that's a statement okay alright and it's
a degree and it's it's it's it's you
know you're ungrateful I defend myself
now he's not ungrateful you can go ahead
he might try to defend yourself a couple
scenarios here okay go ahead
one I am taking these no not zero
meetings exactly I knew that response
would get you so crowd up because of my
other mentor that taught me that who
debt fan mm-hmm what did that fan teach
you to capture how people you're always
taking meetings tell people you're
always filming and always hashtag bones
so you learned it from your other
mentors yeah you told me it was the yin
the yang
I can't learn everything right again let
me tell you this right now okay you
ungrateful [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] all
three of you oh what the [ __ ] did I do
all three of you number one my boy DP is
killing it right now Wow okay for
Network shows but in the last four
months how did you know about that
through his Instagram oh okay number two
firstly checks when he wakes up in the
morning kills it
he's killing the game yeah and for me to
even complain you know is me being
jealous cuz I got nothing going on
that's right you don't none of us here
have anything going on Dilbert you're
not in a hashtag dramedy right now okay
protect ear maybe yeah and you're not in
hashtag bones and you're not in hashtag
crackle and you're not in hashtag CBS as
an extra so no he's got a speaking role
and he's gotten a character and then
look at guest star you're not any fancy
hashtags Gilbert such a savior though
you know I want you to apologize now
quit now anyone listening to right now
you [ __ ] don't tell him we're
talking about him or tag close or tag
his/her name someone tagged me yeah I
mean cuz he's killing it and we're just
being jealous I'm gay I think we would
agree with that yeah yeah I think we're
being haters
we're being hater because you know what
he's done nothing
to us and we're literally sick were
singling him out because it's funny and
it is [ __ ] funny it's not funny
it's funny so funny I'm sorry but I have
a blast just going through his Instagram
it's my it's one source of amusement for
me he's doing great and you're being
jealous and your boyfriend's a loser
because I got nothing going on and I'm
just talking like because I got nothing
going on and now I feel I look jealous
yeah let me just say this to me look
look at me right now
let me ask you a question yeah did you
call Lawrence yet never calling a Monday
also you had day and Friday to college
you haven't called them yet no not yet
so five days have passed five days have
passed whole industry is closed on
Friday at five o'clock so did you call
him I was gonna call today and I
realized no because it's Monday and it's
like what are you talking about what the
[ __ ] are you learning these Gilbert
listen to this if Bobby calls him the
day before you'll be thought about
you're not on the call again now he's
forgotten about you I made a mistake
then you have to go it's over now don't
call yes not over yeah I know
no no yeah all right look at me right
now
don't call him I see where you're coming
your other meetings you probably didn't
want to come off as desperate which I
understand all my [ __ ] friend just
[ __ ] sign this the [ __ ] ungrateful
[ __ ] right he's not ungrateful
he does so much for us for this product
you do think it's so hard
thank you so does pink boy pink does too
pink does more pink he does - he doesn't
think does more I think that's the most
he does the most yeah we just show up
when we talk bunch of that fan [ __ ]
yeah no baby come on come on what he's
doing great let's I'm fun of him he's a
good guy he's alright god damn man I
love the guy I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
you could look at a camera right now and
so you loved the guy loved him you can
lie to win - huh no it's not later one
not one of those I love the guy anyways
okay let's move on what did you guys
think of the Oscars oh I loved it was
funny he didn't watch it he hates
watching that stuff I hate him he was
boring [ __ ] oh my lord I wasn't born a
white Chris's monologue upfront yeah
I mean there was that one bit we were
talking about that he did with a man on
the street with the black people watch
movies I thought that was it that didn't
bother me as much as the it's like the
the push for diversity is one thing but
it really wasn't a push for a diversity
it was a push more so for just black
people in general because they took a
giant [ __ ] on Asians with that with that
joke yeah why would that the joke was
they had three like Asian kids with like
briefcases come out and said and the
joke was that they were bankers and that
if you're angry about that you can he
mate so it was basically a joke about
Asians being smart and Asians and child
labour which is fine whatever I'm not
sensitive about any of that but I'm
saying it's like the only reason I
thought it to be just a little bit silly
it was because as this Washington Post
author put it there was a lack of
diversity in their push for diversity
yeah it was mostly about African
Americans versus Latinos Asians or
everybody as a whole it was such a push
for you know Oscar so white oh you know
Oscar not black enough but it was that's
it that's where it ended there was lack
of diversity in there listen listen to
me right now
Hollywood is in the business of making
money period okay what they think I'll
just tell you this okay
well right I do a joke about that movie
21 right yeah a mighty students and
stuff and they it was like mostly Asian
yeah yeah yeah anyway so um what one of
the producers I hope to stay say Kevin
Spacey was confronted or whatever about
it and he said you know it's about you
know making money and they you know
people don't believe that if they put
Asians you know mean Americans in a
movie that it's gonna draw any kind of
revenue the people are not gonna want to
watch it because of the fact that it's
never really happened before you know I
mean if you have you know mean and like
John Chow lead a movie and it's the
number one movie in the country then
they would change but he is you know
like helping Kumar I'm not that I love
John a love Cal and I
of you know I mean I love the movie I
was in the movie you know I mean I loved
the whole thing and I don't give a [ __ ]
if white people like it or whatever you
know man
but it's like in their opinion you know
it's like we have to put you mean but
how are they even how would they even
know if not one blockbuster movie ever
had a white male protagonist like how
could they even well they know I like
for instance that one movie another 21
and up where they put that Asian guy in
it you know I mean I don't know who that
blockbuster movie justin chon yeah yeah
yeah my point is is that they put people
you mean Asians in like big leads in
things and they don't generate huge
amounts of money but it's a different
day and age like this is there's so many
different avenues to make money now and
you realize that in terms of just the
Earth's population you have a [ __ ]
ton of Asian so you will get your money
back and more if you just gave it a shot
i 100% agree with you but I also I'm
just telling you how they look at it you
know and it's like you don't see it
changing right say like next 20 years
still the same thing today 20 years from
now I don't know and I my opinion is is
that because I don't want this is a very
touchy to subject because I audition for
things and I honor yeah I'm a guy that
goes out and tries to book acting work
and stuff and it's like I don't get
hired and I don't people go how come
they don't hire you I really began
anything because I'm probably not that
good I mean I mean if I think about it
it's like people go well Ken Jong you
know Randall Park all these guys are
booking stuff ahead of you how about not
you in my opinion now and that for a
while I was like yeah why not and now
I'm really beginning to think that I'm
probably not that good that's why I
wouldn't say that well I'm that's what
I'm
[Music]